last night in the house of
representatives the democrats brought up
a vote on enshrining this new definition
of marriage this radical definition of
marriage of the fundamental political
unit
into law
and 47 house republicans voted for it
47 house republicans did not vote to
get the government out of marriage which
i think is an impossibility but it's
still a broadly popular position on the
right they didn't do that they went much
further than that 47 house republicans
did not vote to accept the results of
the obergefell case from the supreme
court
that's not what this vote was about they
did a lot more than that they voted
affirmatively to radically redefine
marriage family the fundamental unit of
society and they voted to do it for no
reason whatsoever the obergefell case is
not in any way at risk the supreme court
made that extremely clear in their dobbs
decision justice thomas is the only
judge on the court who has expressed a
willingness to revisit the obergefell
decision none of the other judges none
of the other conservative judges said
that they would do that they wouldn't
sign on to the the concurrence from
thomas there is no risk whatsoever
at the moment or in the foreseeable
future to that definition of marriage
the democrats only brought this issue up
as a wedge issue
to trap republicans and these 47
useless squishes
took the bait hook
line
and sinker it is so pathetic what are
their names i'm going to read their
names up here drives me so it's so
frustrating that these people they can't
win for freaking losing these
republicans they take the bait every
time they can't be counted on to
conserve anything at all if you can't
conserve the fundamental basic political
unit if you can't conserve the
difference between men and women you
can't conserve anything so good they're
going to vote with us on tax cuts maybe
sometimes cool great a lot of good that
does here they are these are their names
kelly armstrong
don bacon cliff bentz ken calvert cat
kamek that's disappointing i like cat
comic but it's very disappointing what
she did mike carey liz cheney of course
john curtis rodney davis maria
diaz-balart tom emmer brian fitzpatrick
andrew garberino mike garcia carlos
gimenez tony gonzalez anthony gonzalez
ashley henson daryl issa chris jacobs
david joyce john catko adam kinzinger of
course
nancy mace nicole malliotakis brian mast
peter mager dan muser marionette miller
meeks blake moore dan newhouse j
obernolte burgess owens burgess owens
come on in utah utah they're going to
vote to completely redefine marriage
scott perry tom rice maria elvira
salazar mike simpson at least oh there's
these the rest of these squishes are
lucky because my page cut out on my
print you're lucky i know at least
stefanik is the next one okay five or
six republicans are lucky that i don't
get to
that i don't get to read their names on
air because this didn't print correctly
don't worry maybe i'll read it tomorrow
i'm so i'm just so
frustrated with these guys
the
one if you don't
if you don't have
the
moral clarity on this issue or at least
the political clarity to know huh this
this really matters i know a lot of
republicans want to say oh who cares
it's not a big deal you know who cares
the democrats care the democrats have
been putting a lot of time and energy
and focus into this issue for a long
time and they care because they know
that it matters because if you can
redefine men and women then you can do
anything you can take any amount of
political power
a lot of conservatives will say well
look i don't care about the marriage
issue i just want to stop this crazy
transgender stuff
but what those conservatives don't
realize is
the transgender stuff is the marriage
issue the marriage issue leads
inevitably to the transgender stuff
because what the redefinition of
marriage says is that men and women are
exactly the same that there is no
significant difference between men and
women
that's the only way that the union of a
man and a woman that we call marriage
can be the exact same as the union of a
man and a man or the union of a woman
and a woman the only way they can be
exactly the same and we use the same
word to refer to all of them is if men
and women are exactly the same which is
the essential premise of transgenderism
that men and women are fundamentally the
same that's why a man can secretly be a
woman and a woman can secretly be a man
that's
that's
so
so frustrating that these people don't
get it but they don't conserve anything
and they don't even know how to play
washington games the democrats are
pushing this right now because not
because it's an urgent issue
obergefell's not going anywhere they're
pushing it right now because they're
losing on every urgent issue before the
country so they're just trying to find
wedge votes
and they know that the republicans are
split pretty much 50 50 on this i
took my very scientific poll on twitter
the other day
and it reflected what what people who
have been looking at the numbers would
expect from the gop
the gop is split here and the democrats
don't want republican unity going into
the midterms
and so these squishes here they very
easily could have said this is a
ridiculous vote it's a show vote you
democrats are just putting us up to it
it's so we're not going to take the bait
this is not an urgent issue they could
the republicans could have held firm but
these ones can't because they care much
more about what the new york times says
about them than what their own base says
about them or what reality says about
them or conserving a damn thing it's
just
so pathetic the only the only silver
lining in this confusion and
disappointment regarding the public view
of marriage
is benefer that's the only silver lining
okay when we're talking about marriage
yes i meant to get to it yesterday i'm
so glad i could get to it today
after what 15 years 18 years
two-thirds of my life maybe
ben affleck
and
what's her name jennifer lopez jennifer
lopez affleck
they finally tied the knot so many years
20 years after g lee
took the silver screen by storm ben
affleck and jennifer lopez have gotten
married right now go to goodranchers.com
knowles in president reagan's farewell
address he said all great change in
america begins at the dinner table bring
your family to the dinner table with
good ranchers good ranchers cares deeply
about providing families with high
quality meat at a reasonable price good
ranches ships 100 american meat born
raised and harvested in the united
states right to your door they age every
cut to perfection they give you that
true steakhouse experience right in your
own home plus when you subscribe your
price is locked in for the life of your
subscription
i love good ranchers when i was a kid
having steak was a very special occasion
we'd go maybe you'd get steak's pretty
expensive good ranchers brings you
insanely high quality steak for an
extremely low price from america i love
these steaks i love the new york strip
is my favorite their wagyu burgers are
amazing but the rib eyes are good the
t-bones all of their stuff i love their
chicken too actually better than organic
chicken they're great and they're huge
supporters of the daily wire so uh it's
a it's a wonderful relationship we're
big fans of theirs they're big fans of
ours
go check them out you are absolutely
going to love them use code knowles k o
w l e s to get your steakhouse
experience for 30 bucks off plus free
shipping on your order shipping is not
cheap this is a lot of top quality meat
so take advantage of this incredible
offer goodranchers.com knowles start
bringing people back to the table and
eating seriously delicious food
already bought from good ranchers well
that's great show me what you're making
post a photo of your meal tag me and our
friends over at good ranchers so they
can see it too
i actually do kind of care about the
jennifer lopez ben affleck story
i don't i assume i don't know anything
really about these people's personal
lives i assume they've all been married
a hundred times i'm not totally sure
that the the benefit of marriage that
just took place is the most illicit
marriage in the world i think it took
place in the elvis chapel in vegas
somewhere and
these guys may have been married before
and anyway whatever
the the
aspect of the story that i find somewhat
heartwarming and actually important for
the public to pay attention to is
they got back together those kids
finally worked it out
these guys were both extremely famous
extremely successful they
were i don't think they were married
they were engaged they were dating and
then they broke it off and they went
with all sorts of other people and i'm
sure that they
gorged themselves on the pleasures of
single life
and even after all of that
they wound up back together they
realized that something more valuable
than just going and screwing around for
your whole life and being single and
just living for yourself something more
valuable than that ben affleck
is a wealthy famous man he could he
could be dating or marry a 22 year old
of his choice right now that's just the
way hollywood works and he didn't
they they said the thing that's most
valuable
is
is that old thing to get that old thing
back again
someone with whom you have shared
experience someone that you've lived
with for a little bit to kind of come
back uh i don't know the particulars of
benefir but i do know that's an
important lesson for a lot of people
especially in our culture which is a
swipe right culture where you're told
that if if you're dating someone in high
school it would be preposterous to think
that you could ever marry that person oh
that's correct that's what they did in
the old days before we had tinder now oh
no you have to break up you for sure
have to break up for college and you've
got to date a hundred thousand people
and i don't even want to use the word
date you should just be in a hookup
culture and you go out and you
you go sleep with somebody and then
maybe you introduce yourself to that
person the next morning when you wake up
possibly you go get breakfast but you
don't you don't really live for anybody
else you certainly don't make any
decisions that would affect your life
for anyone else you don't make decisions
about where you're going to live or your
job your career your school you don't do
any of that for anybody else you live
entirely for yourself and for your
career and the widget factory you're
going to work at and then if a spouse
fits into that picture that's fine but
maybe you're just going to live in a
studio apartment forever and just keep
swiping right right right and going on
meaningless dates and have casual sex
and then at the end
you will have i don't know gotten the
promotion at work or something that's
what our modern culture
tells everybody to do and it's really
right you want to talk about radical
redefinitions of marriage and the
relationship between men and women
that's a radical redefinition
and what are the fruits of that people
are getting married much later if at all
they're having many fewer children if
they have any at all and they're
freaking miserable people are miserable
they're depressed antidepressant use is
through the roof the average life
expectancy in america is declining
because of deaths of despair because of
suicide because of drug overdoses is
this entirely about the the collapse of
the american family and the decline in
marriage and the bizarre way that we
approach sex and human relationships
it's probably not entirely that but i
bet it's a lot of that because that's
the central aspect of human life
without which all the money in the world
means absolutely nothing
take that take that lesson from bennifer
and if benifer is an imperfect vessel
for that message learn the lesson
anyway and also when are we going to get
the glee reboot i am here for the glee
reboot it's been way too long bring it
on
i'm glad you like that clip we are
so close to a million subscribers i'm
very excited for this because then i'll
get my gold plaque and then youtube will
nuke me and they'll cast me into the
outer darkness and wailing and gnashing
of teeth and if that's what's gonna
happen so be it darn it make sure that
you ring that bell subscribe get the
notifications get me my gold play button
statue we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you